so i think it's very clear even though
we're just over 10 days into this war
that predicting precise outcomes is
probably a fool's errand i think what
we're seeing
is a russian armed forces that are
struggling
to take ukraine
we're seeing a remarkable fight back
from both ukrainian armed forces and the
civilian population
and we're seeing the world come together
to apply pressure on russia
and so this is going to be a tough fight
this is going to be a long fight and
it's very hard to predict nice neat
outcomes
do you think russia has committed war
crimes
yes
i think the indiscriminate nature of the
russian violence is shocking
i'm delighted that the international
criminal court have already started
their investigations and i think
russia's armed forces need to be on
alert
for those investigations and the
inevitability of war crimes particularly
as they carry on their violence and
particularly as it gets more and more
reckless
will the uk provide ukrainian military
with more weapons and what would we be
talking about
so i
i'm the uk was one of the first
definitely the first in europe to start
providing lethal aid the defense
secretary just over a week ago held a
donor's conference and that brought
together 25 nations
to pool their resources to increase both
lethal and non-lethal aid and the uk's
being clear that we will continue to
provide both lethal and non-lethal aid
and that's anti-tank weapons but it's
also other weapons but it would i don't
want to go into the detail of some of
those weapons they will be defensive in
nature and we are clear that this is
going to be long-term support to ukraine
when you say you don't want to go into
detail is that actually for strategic
reasons as in to keep it a secret from
russia no i think it's about being
really clear that what the uk is
providing is both lethal and non-lethal
aid
um it's to avoid us getting into precise
numbers is to avoid us getting into the
intricacies of this weapon over that
weapon we've been clear we'll provide
lethal and non-lethal aid and that then
the lethal aid will be defensive in
nature
how concerned are you that putin might
resort to nuclear weapons
so i we
we are a nuclear nation we have our own
nuclear deterrent we're part of the
world's largest and most powerful
military alliance
we we need to be
very clear
and we need to be calm and responsible
and not react to threats from president
putin
so we have our own defenses we have our
ability to respond we monitor russia
very very carefully
we have been
explicit
in highlighting to russia that this is
a tragic war that's going on in ukraine
the there is there's an imperative that
it doesn't escalate even in conventional
terms and it would be insane for this to
start a path towards a nuclear
escalation escalation so we are ready
and prepared and very clear
of our responsibilities and our ability
to respond but we don't see ourselves
as
as as responding to every comment that
president putin makes
what more can be done we've got you know
the support in terms of lethal and
non-lethal aid there are the sanctions
what are the next steps
so the next steps are resolve the next
steps are to maintain our unity maintain
our cohesion and maintain our resolve
and we will see
increased violence we'll see more sadly
death and destruction on in ukraine and
we have to maintain our our
international resolve our international
pressure because the person who can
bring this to it to an end and to a
swift end is putin and the pressure
needs to be applied on russia and it's
it's that continued resolve that
continued unity and the cohesion across
military diplomatic economic political
social cultural aspects that will bear
down on russia
do you think putin might actually want
to go further moldova
georgia baltic states
there's a risk
that
putin and what he said and
his ambitions
for a greater russia might involve those
countries but i think what you're seeing
is a president putin who is failing
an invasion that is struggling a russia
that is a lesser power this week than it
was last week because of the the
application of the world the world's
economic pressure its social political
cultural pressure
applying itself to russia so russia is a
lesser nation and that needs to continue